[Music]
i could feel my pills
finally slowing down all day my heart
had been thumping with anticipation
but the moment i'd been dreading was
finally over
after weeks of intense preparation i had
just delivered my final presentation
in my freshman year business
communications class
i was thrilled with my performance
leaving the class i was on such a high i
knew that i had nailed it
and that i probably left every one of my
classmates filled with
inspiration the next day i ran into one
of my peers who was in the class the day
before
we got to talking about our final
presentations and
in one quick sentence she absolutely
crushed me
she asked me so are you excited to get
yours over with next week
i was devastated that presentation that
i had been feeling
so good about yesterday hadn't even left
a dent in her memory
after all that work i was completely
forgotten
that day i learned an important lesson
with all the things that our audiences
hear and are exposed to on a daily basis
it's very easy for what you say to be
forgotten
but fortunately since then i've also
learned that it's just as easy
to be memorable
of course being memorable feels good on
the old ego
but it's also critical to make sure that
your content stays top of mind
amongst all of today's distractions
particularly in the business world
people are inundated with presentations
and pitches
each of us after we graduate will
probably hear at least one presentation
per day
and for those of us who are aspiring
entrepreneurs
a top of the top these see at least 50
presentations
per week with all those presentations
competing for your
audience's attention it's important to
stand out
but standing out alone isn't enough
according to a yale study
20 minutes after a presentation the
audience only remembered about 60
of the presenter's content after half a
day
that number dropped to 40 and after just
one week
audience members remembered only about
10 of what was said to them just a week
before
the tips we'll give you today will help
make sure that your presentation isn't
one of the ones that's forgotten
by using the few tips that we outlined
today you'll find that it's easy to be
memorable
aiden that introduction itself showed me
how to be memorable
your storytelling caught my attention
and honestly i felt surprised when it
took a turn
this is a great segue into our first
tactic shock the audience
let's start by watching the beginning of
pablo zapata's low keynote
during which he tells a story of an
incredible dive he experienced
this could be the dive i've always
dreamed of
as i descended i was surrounded by over
70 sharks
from different species we reached
the sandy floor and from the semicircle
my mom
was to my left i started shooting away
my favorite a beautiful lemon shark
arrived finally
20 minutes into the dive the thing i've
been waiting for
two massive tiger sharks one of them
measuring over 15 feet in length
they started circling the group and
getting close
very close as the larger
of the two sharks swung past me
heading towards my mom i saw its eye
turn white something they do right
before biting
the shark suddenly turned and smacked me
with its tail i lost my balance
but as soon as i regained it i clicked
the shutter and saw the scariest image
i've ever taken
the shark took a bite at my mom
pablo goes on to talk about his love of
the ocean and to promote ocean
conservatism
and how the ocean should be a
sustainable food source but
what a way to start and capture the
audience's attention
pablo used twists and turns in a story
and used stunning
frankly scary visuals especially to
someone who is
deathly afraid of sharks like i am
these are both great tactics to shock
the audience especially from the get-go
we all know from experience how critical
the first 30 seconds of a presentation
can be
other great tactics to shock the
audience are the use of props
like roberto during his presentation
sensory effects
like a loud noise or a surprising
statistic
for example in his presentation of the
original ipod
steve jobs uses to statistic 1000 songs
in your pocket to shock the audience
this statistic was so powerful that it
went on to become the ipod's tagline
why is it so important to shock the
audience
often times we don't come to a
presentation with our listening caps on
we know what this situation is we're
distracted or tired from everything that
life's thrown our way
and the last thing we're ready to do is
engage with the presentation
but that's why it's critical to shock
the audience
it's easy to be memorable if you shock
and once your audience has recovered
from the shock how do you sustain
attention
one trick we've learned on that front is
to show
don't tell to avoid making ourselves
into complete hypocrites
let us show you what we mean with two
examples
take a moment to feel the difference in
imagery experience
and emotion that comes from hearing two
versions of the same reality
one michael is struggling with some
serious zoom fatigue
two as the professor started speaking
all michael could hear was the silent
scream of his pounding headache
he had only spent three hours on zoom
that day but his eyes
and brain had decided to give up
the first example is factual and to the
point
while you were listening you probably
understood that yes
michael like many of us is indeed
feeling
some zoom fatigue the second example
however
pulled you into michael's shoes you felt
his pounding headache
perhaps literally and figuratively and
his sense of resignation
at his fate and if you didn't feel a
little more pulled in by that example
well you might be a sociopath
for our second example let's watch a
former gs beer
giving a low keynote about how to manage
anxiety
so how about we handle this situation
like a pro
and pause
reframe
maybe spilling juice all over myself
makes this more entertaining for you
and there'll be more views
and own i'm not feeling what i'm feeling
right now because i spilled juice over
myself
it's because i had an expectation
internally that this toggle followed
execute the steps of his personal
framework
for managing anxiety pause reframe
and own pulkit shocked the audience into
attention
and brought his advice to life in the
most realistic way possible
by handling it like a pro so the next
time you're working through a
presentation
think about michael and paulken when
you're trying to communicate
a data point or effect how might you use
story to bring it to life when you're
giving a recommendation
or a piece of advice could you find a
way to demonstrate it to your audience
as pulkit showed us it could be as easy
as finding a red drink
to spill on your white shirt it's easy
to be memorable
if you show don't tell
it's easy to be memorable show me with
your fingers how many times you hear
this phrase today
twice three times someone's saying seven
and you still hear this a couple more
times because this that's the mantra
of our presentation sound bites that
we're emphasizing
over and over for you to associate it
with the delivery
monitors and sound bites are some of the
easiest ways to remember any type of
historical moment
in fact let's go back in time for a bit
what's the first thing that comes to
mind if i ask you about the moon landing
that's one small step for men one giant
leap for mankind
what if i ask you about obama
even the most passionate republican will
think
yes we can does it work with
presentations
steve jobs iphone launch reinvent
the phone for my international friends
is it a us only thing no in brazil
every single person knows that on the
event of brazil's independence from
portugal
the emperor said independence or
death but the qualifieds and mantras
didn't just come to their minds in the
middle of these historical moments
they're carefully crafted and prepared
beforehand
armed with your message there are three
ways to stick it into your audience's
memories
number one repeat the phrase
over and over number two
punctuated with a pause
that gives them time to process and
write it down
number three project the words in the
slide
this creates visual stimulus for their
memories
remember it's easy
to be memorable
finally here are some rhetorical devices
that will help you assemble
an unforgettable mantra number one
imitate a famous phrase so for example
the golden rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
could become never give a presentation
you wouldn't want to sit through
yourself number two
repeat words at the beginning of a
series
it was the best of times it was the
worst of times
it was the age of wisdom it was the age
of foolishness
charles dickens a tale of two cities
number three repeat the words in the
middle of a series
on every side yet not distressed
were perplexed but not in despair
persecuted but not forsaken
cast down but not destroyed
apostle paul to the corinthians and
finally number four
you you got it repeat words at the end
of the series and that government
of the people by the people for the
people
shall not perish from the earth lincoln
on his famous gettysburg address it's
easy to be memorable
if you have a mantra
thinking back to my final presentation
all those years ago
i can now see that it was totally
forgettable i didn't shock the audience
i definitely told rather than showing
and i didn't have a mantra
no wonder my talk didn't stand out among
a huge roster of final presentations
maybe you've also given a presentation
that no one remembered
or maybe you've been in a popcorn style
team check-in where you were called on
twice because no one remembered you
already gave your update
no matter what the scenario these tips
can help you to be more memorable
in your next speaking engagement we'd
like to encourage you to try one of the
tactics we suggested
shock the audience show don't tell or
maybe have a mantra
with these tips you guessed it
it's easy to be memorable